and so
what what's Network formations I decided
to make a small introduction so in
general models can be structural and a
structural model can see what property
the network does have for example the
network would have power log a power or
degree distribution a generative model
tells you whether there is a plausible
physical or combinatorial explanation
for the structural model for example
potential attachment is a is a great uh
explanation of the structural model
but this is a plausible model it's
something that makes sense but it
doesn't necessarily have to be validated
Network formation on the other hand is
is it approvable or validated pathway
towards the structural model so the bar
here is a little bit higher it's not
just plausible as in a generative model
but something that actually happens
and so there are many Pathways to
network formation
as it turns out my slides are going to
go in the reverse order of the speakers
right so the first pathway is behavioral
and here we model how individuals
actually behave when they're forming a
network with each other like we don't we
need to understand we don't really
understand how what they're thinking and
we're just trying to understand how they
are behaving
and so we you can use this analytically
derived models of the final Network just
from the behavior and verify the model
as well as the final structure using
real data and Michael Kunz is going to
talk about it he's wearing a different
shirt today but yesterday the closer you
were wearing yesterday were exactly
in distinguishable from what he's
wearing in this picture
but it's like black and white look
exactly like
a little bit oh yeah okay sorry
I wasn't looking that closely
but he's going to talk about some
Behavior
well not everyone has a
not having a Steve Jobs like dressing
the thing I think life is hard to do it
for everybody
so Michael has his lab among the other
things he has done he also has a lab
that he runs on the side where he does
behavioral experiments to see how
undergrass actually act using undergrads
so there's guinea pigs to figure out how
networks actually form and I'm I'm
assuming that's what he's going to talk
about
the next Pathway to network formation is
strategic we're trying to understand
what individuals are thinking what they
want not just how they're behaving
and so once again you can use this
analytically derived models of the final
Network you can tweak rules of the game
such as benefits individuals cost to
them the functionality in the network to
achieve desired outcomes right so it's a
bit more like you want to influence
something and these models of course
need to be trackable
and this is a big uh it's a big agenda
so no one talk is going to cover the
whole agenda but Matt is going to talk
about Matt Jackson who's uh a colleague
in uh from the Stanford Business School
in economics is going to talk about uh
strategic models of network formation
and then another password Network
formation which is completely uh sort of
separate from the ones that we have
talked about so far we had been talking
about individuals we can also talk about
molecules and a physical model could be
you model how molecules act when they
interact with each other
and how that affects biological
functionality and when you who's a
statistician in Berkeley is going to
talk about
uh
about that and I don't understand this
very well so I'm going to say anything
more about this part
and and finally these models need to be
tractable and what that means is we need
models that are tractable so you can
work within the parameters are estimable
you can't have a model whose estimated
whose parameters itself is like an
optimization problem which is going to
take you on a four-year research part to
solving that just finding parameters of
that model you can make predictions in
them with the model the model is useful
only if you can use it to make
predictions you have to be able to
verify your predictions and hypotheses
and then these models seem to be
somewhat sparse the parameters need to
be few in number
and Arun Chandra shekar who's uh a
colleague from Stanford also business
school who I just met and so I wasn't
actually sure this is the right picture
was very bloody so it wouldn't imagine
he's going to talk about
some aspects of and again this is a big
research agenda but he's going to talk
about challenge challenges of modeling
Network formation intractable ways
and all of this is adding up to five
minutes it tense I thought I'll also
give an example there's an example from
my own research where I feel like we've
been able to get to the structural part
and we are stuck on the network
formation part
so is this an example for example are
these Network formation models if they
existed and which you don't have could
be hugely influential
so we want to understand Precision on
social networks among the information
that lands in your timeline how much is
relevant to you right and this is uh
there is two
different means one is that people are
addicted to social networks the other is
the media keeps talking about why do I
want to understand what do I want to see
whether someone had coffee or not
and so what we observed for this
interest on users on social networks
they have a clustered structure so these
are sort of various interests and these
are similarities between so I'm
interested in x that's not independent
of whether I'm interested in y
uh and then we also notice that users
have brought a consumption of interest
and narrower production interest the set
of things I want to learn about or I'm
going to read the set of news articles
I'm going to read is much broader than
the set of news articles I'm going to
actually tweet about or write about
and so you can look at interest
distributions and you can see that the
typically a user consumes eight
interests and and talks about four
and then what we observed was we could
show that these two factors together
lead could lead to social networks being
high precision and we verify that on
Twitter so among 10 people we ask them
to rate Tweets in their timeline in blue
and random to is in red and you could
see that
the average Precision or the average
relevance of tweets the average fraction
of research in their own timeline which
user software element was around 80 and
random things are completely
uninteresting to people
and so all of this is good right but
what what does have to do with network
formation
uh we have no idea how this network
forms
how do people with similar interest
group together says the network is high
precision
we also don't know why it forms that way
right so so this is like the how and the
why the how is behavioral the why is
more strategic why do users act the way
they do
and if you understand the how and the
why so if you understand this network
formation question we can influence the
process to achieve higher Precision so
when you go to Facebook maybe you will
get
uh you'll have better friends and so
maybe you'll get better uh better
Facebook feed you can increase both in
social networks and you can do better
recommendation systems and advertising
and these last two bullets are the meat
are the main challenges two main
challenges faced by long-term challenges
faced by social networks like Facebook
and Twitter so so in in a sense if we
had a good understanding of network
formation it could be hugely hugely
influential so with that uh I'm going to
introduce the first Speaker from
Stanford